[Música]
hoy en directo a vamos a la ciudad de
Miami porque el congreso Estatal de
Florida va a discutir un proyecto de ley
que busca acortar aún más el periodo
durante el que las personas con
capacidad de gestar pueden Acceder al
aborto recordemos que desde julio de
2022 sólo se puede acceder a esta
práctica hasta las 15 semanas en lugar
de las veinticuatro establecidas hasta
ese momento para ampliar la información
conectamos con Antonio belchiles
corresponsal de France 24 Antony
exactamente qué es lo que propone este
proyecto de ley presentado Por los
republicanos y Qué posibilidades tiene
de ser aprobado
Pues sí Valentina qué tal Muy buenas
noches pues este proyecto de ley lo ha
presentado la senadora republicana erin
gral y lo que dice este proyecto de ley
básicamente es que se debe restringir el
plazo del aborto legal a las seis
semanas de embarazo tal y como apuntaban
desde el estudio desde el 1 de julio de
2022 ya se limitó ese plazo a las 15
semanas de gestación frente a las 24
semanas que se contemplaban hasta ese
entonces y sí hay muchas posibilidades
de que este proyecto de ley siga
adelante básicamente Porque contaría con
el apoyo del gobernador de Florida el
republicano ron de santis y porque
básicamente el congreso Estatal es de
mayoría republicana hay que recordar
también que a pesar de todas las
restricciones que hubo en Florida con la
cuestión del aborto aumentaron los
abortos legales en 2022 hubo más de
82.000 abortos legales frente a los poco
más de 7 9.000 de 2021 y todo eso tiene
una explicación Y es que más de 6.000
personas llegaron hasta el estado de
Florida procedentes de Estados como Luis
Diana Mississippi Georgia o Tejas donde
las leyes de la de aborto son mucho más
restrictivas Anthony que
pronunciamientos se han producido al
respecto
pues automáticamente miembros del
partido demócrata también de
organizaciones como Planet Hood lo que
han dicho es que se está siguiendo las
órdenes directas del gobernador de
Florida porque quiere utilizar el tema
del aborto como juego político para su
posible candidatura a las elecciones
presidenciales de Estados Unidos y
recuerdan que esta ley lo que haría es
perder poder de las mujeres y niñas a
decidir sobre su cuerpo su vida y Su
futuro también recuerdan que muchas
optarían por no utilizar los servicios
de atención primaria y optarían por
opciones clandestinas mucho más
peligrosas Pero también dicen que está
por ver por lo que todo lo que pueda
acabar diciendo la Corte Suprema en este
sentido teniendo en cuenta que ya el año
pasado también
impuso medidas mucho más restrictivas en
el asunto del aborto